Welcome back everyone
it's Charlie
HBO just announce House of the Dragon
Season 3 and some changes of the story
of season 2.
With that moving some major plot points
around, as well as the final end
point of the series in season four
and what their plan is for moving
the timeline to the next major event
in Targaryen history
after the end of the Dance of the Dragons.
So there's a whole bunch of stuff going
on. We'll break it all down.
If you're brand new to the channel,
are doing videos for all the episodes
just like I did
for the original Game of Thrones series.
Be sure to subscribe to get all those
all explained which plot points
they move from season two to season three.
They were very specific about that
just because of the way that they were
plotting out the rest of the show
through season four.
The first big news is that they reduced
the episode count for season two.
As much as that sucks,
like everyone took a huge L for that.
The major reason was because they'd
already renewed the show for season three
in Plotted out which major events
they wanted to cover in season
three and decided the major battle
they were originally going to end season
two on would fit better
with the part of the dance
the Dragons they were doing during season
three.
I'll explain what
I think that is in a second.
But how's the Dragon?
Season two is now eight episodes,
but what we've lost in
two episodes, we've gained
in two more confirmed seasons, basically.
They didn't officially renew it
for season four yet,
but they do plan to renew it much earlier
now, just so that there isn't a big delay
between season three and season four.
But this is part of the reason
for shuffling the story around so much
so that they could plan out, get season
three going now, start working on scripts
while they're still working on season two.
Just very early days,
so there would not be a long break
between season two in season three.
As you've all probably seen currently,
Season two won't premiere until summer
2024.
That's nearly two years after season one,
which really does suck.
The reason why the break is so long
is because it takes them so much longer
to turn a season around
than it used to at the beginning
of the original Game of Thrones series.
You probably remember
this slowly happening
across the original Game of Thrones
series.
In the early seasons,
there weren't a ton of visual effects,
so they were able to turn seasons around
relatively close to a year.
But as they got to season
six, season seven, season eight,
the Dragons got bigger, the visual effects
got bigger, the battles got bigger.
Then when we got to the house,
the Dragons series, that trend
just continued even more visual effects.
So you have months and months
and months of post-production tacked on
to the end of actual production.
That's where most of this extra production
time comes from.
It also to boot, because it took them
so long to get House of the Dragon out.
After the original Game of Thrones ended,
they waited till very late to like right
after House of the Dragon had premiered
before they renewed it for season two.
Normally they would have renewed it
much sooner
and we're sort of working on season
two much sooner.
So Ryan Condal,
the showrunner, and George R.R.
Martin, who is heavily
involved in developing the show,
everyone else working on scripts, starting
pre-production, plotting out the season,
didn't actually sit down
to start working on season two
until after it had been renewed.
So we just way, way later than they would
normally have started working on it.
That's how they were able to get
the original Game of Thrones series out
every single year, pretty reliably
up to the last couple of seasons.
HBO had renewed the show way
further in advance
that they knew
they were going to be working on it
so they could start working
it much sooner.
So the real blame here
kind of lies with HBO dragging their feet
now that they've confirmed
House of the Dragon is a huge hit,
we're not going to see as big of a break
between seasons in the future.
Thankfully, didn't really take a genius
to figure out
that it was going to be super popular.
The same thing will continue after they
finished covering the Dance of the Dragon.
So I'll explain that later in the video
because that will involve
the next part of the timeline
that they jump to after season four.
The next big thing was that huge battle
that they cut from the end of season two.
Those two episodes, they moved to season
three the way they plotted out season two,
Blood and cheese
and the assault on Herron Hall
were going to happen
at the beginning of the season.
Two very different types of events in
terms of scale like one is a huge battle.
Another is a really small
but very WTF kind of moment.
But both are meant to shake
the foundations of the blacks
and the Greens
and both sides of this conflict.
They really set things off
in a really big way.
Let them really get the actual dance
of the dragon started in a big way.
The actual dance of the Dragons itself
only lasted for about three years,
so it wasn't that long,
but that's the actual fighting itself.
A lot of Season one covers
the lead up to the Dance of the Dragons,
which really didn't begin until
after Rhaenyra had learned that Lucerys
had been killed by Aemond and Vhagar.
That was the whole idea in the finale
is that when they were having
the Black council,
she was having her coronation
with her father's crown.
Otto Hightower had come to try and
make a bargain with them for the Green's.
Rainier has said that they would have
their answer on the morrow.
Then Lucius is killed by Aemond and Vhagar,
and then she decides that it means war.
So on the morrow, they're going to answer
the Green's question
with the answer of war.
Basically,
the actual dance of the Dragons begins.
Later in season two,
we have the Dragon seeds.
I won't talk too much about the events
that lead up to the Dragon Seeds
because they involve some spoilers
for a few of the other major characters
that we saw in Season one.
But this is basically the event
where Jacaerys calls
for as many dragon seeds in the realm
to mount the six riderless dragons
that were currently on Dragonstone
vermouth, the Silver Wing,
Sea Smoke, Sheepstealer,
the Cannibal and Gray Ghost Rainier.
As forces were able to claim some of them
and use them in battle.
None of the dragons
these were able to successfully claim
the wild dragons except for Nettles
claiming sheep stealer.
So nobody claimed the cannibal
or gray ghost.
Couple of people died
trying to get a watch.
A couple more people eaten by some dragons
during season two,
but both those dragons were still involved
in the dance of the Dragons.
They just didn't have writers at the time.
Then I think the battle that they said
they were originally going to end season
two on might be the one that happens
right after Renee
Side calls all the Dragons is to claim
the riderless dragons.
It's the Battle of the Gullet,
which is the area
right between the south edge of drift mark
and the tip of the mainland.
It's the gullet
that literally feeds into Blackwater Bay.
That's why it's called the Gullet.
And it is known as the bloodiest sea
battle in the history of Westeros.
So, you know, you know, it is going to be
a huge battle on the show.
It's a little bit
like Blackwater on steroids
from the original Game of Thrones show.
Like imagine that times ten.
Also, the fact that they're going to use
two episodes to cover it in no spoilers,
but during that battle
there were a lot,
a lot of parallels to what happens
at the end of House
of the Dragon Season one.
So originally
I think what Ryan Condal and George R.R.
Martin had planned for the end of season
two was to end on a similar type
of tense moment
that they ended season one on in.
What they've done now is move that
to early season three made it even bigger.
Like I said, two whole episodes,
meaning that the new House
of the Dragon Season two finale
is probably all about the Dragon seeds
claiming the riderless dragons.
Maybe they'll end on a teaser
at the beginning of the Battle of the Gullet.
Like things get started with the battle
in the end on a cliffhanger in the battle
picks up at the beginning of season
three, There's still a ton of big battles,
a ton of WTF moments in the dance.
The dragons between Aemond and Vhagar
are killing Lucius.
In the Dragons he's showing up so there's
still a lot of them during season two.
It's not like there
won't be any huge battles in season two.
I think they just didn't want to blow too
many of the major battles in season two.
The other side benefit,
just in a practical sense,
is that with two fewer episodes
they can finish season two
and release the episodes way faster
and it becomes much cheaper
for them for HBO because they are spending
like $20 million per episode.
So we're still getting all
that really important stuff.
The really huge battles,
the big events, really crazy stuff.
They're just pacing everything out
between the Four Seasons
now a little bit more carefully.
Also, there's the big reminder here.
The actual Dance of the Dragons
didn't last that long.
Like I said, it basically starts
with Rhaenyra here, finding out about Luke
Cyrus's death, then answering the Green's
with the call to war.
It only lasted for about three years,
like not quite three years.
Season one was mostly about the lead
up to the dance.
The Dragons leaving you with season two,
Season three in season four to cover
those three years of the actual dance.
Probably in the final episode too,
like the season four finale will cover
some of the aftermath as well,
the same way they did
in the original Game of Thrones show.
They covered the aftermath.
What happened to the main characters
directly after that
final battle with Searcy, HBO current plan
for House of the Dragon after Season four,
when they finish the Dance of the Dragons,
is to treat the show like an anthology,
so they'll continue calling it
House of the Dragon.
They'll just do Season five
as a completely different event, jumping
to a different part of the timeline
with a totally different cast of actors.
They'll still be adapting
from the Fire and Blood book.
That's basically a Targaryen history book
written from a couple other perspective.
It's not written
in the same first person perspective,
the different chapters of the Regular,
a Song of Ice and Fire novels is written
more like a history texts
with other masters,
other people like Mushroom The Court for
who is an Easter egg
for during season one.
Just remembering events
in the Targaryen history.
That's how they're able to add details
to each of the episodes.
Like, Oh,
they remembered events a little bit wrong.
Like the things that they heard
about this event in recorded these masters
mushrooms were wrong in A lot of that
extra context comes from George R.R.
Martin. Like George R.R.
Martin wrote, Obviously
the Fire and Blood book and he helped them
write Season one, Season two,
help them write the rest of the show, too.
So it's not like they're just making
stuff up on their own whole cloth.
So like after season four,
there might be like a two year break while
they plot out the next part of history.
How many seasons?
The next part of the show is going to run
in the jump back in time, do Aegon's
conquest and they can jump forward again.
Do the blackfire rebellions
and just continue doing
that, jumping around in the timeline,
treating it like an anthology series.
That's how you wind up getting
ten seasons of House of the Dragon.
It's just a bunch of different events
with a different group of actors.
Each time.
They didn't actually say which event
they planned to do next
after Dance of the Dragons.
I'm actually hoping they go backwards
in the timeline and do Aegon's Conquest x
just because the whole vibe
of the Blackfire
rebellions would feel similar
to what's happening right now
with the dance of the Dragons
in the target in Civil War.
Like a battle
within the family over the succession,
the Blackfire
rebellions are a little bit different
in that it was a battle over
the succession between one of the bastards
who had been legitimized in named himself
black fire in the other legitimate heir
that everybody assumed
would take the throne
after his father Aegon the fourth died.
And that's kind of what's happening right
now, even though it's not a bastard
in the line of succession,
like it's two people
legitimately within the line
fighting for the succession.
Aegon's conquest
is a completely different type event.
Like he's literally
just conquering the six kingdoms
in trying to conquer Dawn unsuccessfully.
There were a lot of Easter eggs
and references to that
during House of the Dragon Season one,
like recontextualizing
the reason
why Aegon conquered the Six Kingdoms
all because of his Dragon dream,
where he saw the coming long night.
He didn't know when it would happen.
He just saw the Night King coming,
this wave of cold washing over the realm.
So the only way for the realm to survive
would be to unite them.
And the only way to do
that would be if he conquered them,
because there was so much infighting
that were happening
between the different realms at the time.
Let me know in the comments if they did
Aegon's Conquest next, who would you
want to play those characters
like Aegon in his two sister Wives?
Also, for those of you
that have wanted them
to do a much bigger version of Robert's
rebellion with like a big series,
they could also do Robert's Rebellion as
another future House of the Dragon series.
They will be filming season
two for most of the rest of this year,
so we'll get more footage and teasers
from the set.
I'll do more bonus videos as we see
more Easter eggs and things pop up.
But if you have any questions
about the characters
or events during season two,
you want me to make videos for
or just write them below in the comments,
everyone click here for my new house
The Dragon Season two teaser video
that HBO just released and click here
for My Full Mandalorian Season
3 Episode 5 Video.
Thank you so much for watching.
Everyone stay safe
and I'll see you guys in the next one.